Speaker 1: I absolutely love this next story.
The supporters of that completely bogus audit of
the 2020 presidential election results in Arizona
are now turning on each other after the
total embarrassing, humiliating flop
in which after months and months of saying
this audit will show us what really happened.
The results were Joe Biden actually won Arizona
by about three hundred and sixty, I believe,
additional votes than what was originally
reported. And as per usual, when things go bad,
Trump supporters just start attacking each other
and blaming. Daily Beast article explains Arizona
audit backers turn on each other after the recount
flop. Our former guest on the show, Will Summer,
wrote this article. Supporters
of Republicans controversial,
quote, audit. I think it makes sense to put that
in quotes. We still don't really know. Is is
this an audit? What is an audit? Supporters of the
audit have turned on each other after the partizan
investigation failed to find proof of election
malfeasance, with disaffected backers even
circulating a fabricated rival report they claim
shows interference by the, quote, deep state.
The audit report landed with a thud on Friday,
only proving, if anything, that Joe Biden won
Arizona by more votes than previously realized.
On this week's episode of The Daily Beast,
Fever Dreams, podcast hosts Asulin Subsetting and
Wil Sommer are joined by Arizona Mirror reporter
Jared MacDonald Devoy to discuss the fractious
aftermath. Some people who were involved in the
report say the deep state kept the real truth out.
Now that's already great because there essentially
some of the people who supported the audit are
saying the deep state infiltrated their own group
and their own audit. That would raise questions
as to whether that's a very trustworthy group
to be doing this at all. If they could be
so easily infiltrated by the deep state,
the deep state and the politically correct lawyers
and rhinos of the Republican Party suppress this,
said MacDonald. Avoid summarizing right wing
critics complaints about the anticlimactic audit
report among the audit report's new detractors,
Joven Hutten, Pulitzer, the controversial
inventor. Who's supposed technology analyzing
full, who's supposed technology, analyzing
folds and paper battling ballot paper had
promised to detect some kind of fraud. Instead,
the final audit report contained no mention of
Pulitzer's imaging technology, a change Pulitzer
attributed on Twitter to deep state malfeasance.
Asked over email who in the deep state supposedly
sabotaged his contribution, Pulitzer remained
vague, vague. That's the big question, is it not?
This is just amazing. Right wing media
personalities disappointed by the audit have
even promoted a fictitious rival report they claim
was the real report from the audit operators cyber
ninjas. In this telling, the fabricated draft
report called for Biden's win to be decertified.
But while the fake report was embraced by
the right wing news blog Gateway Pundit
as proof that the real report had been watered
down, cyber ninjas blasted that report as a hoax.
I think you guys understand they are eating each
other. And there's a big analogy here to the flat
earth. If you get a bunch of flat earth or is in a
room together, they all believe the earth is flat,
but they cite different proofs, supposed proofs
explaining why. And we talked about this actually
recently on the show and some of their
alleged proofs conflict with each other.
They can't possibly be true. Yeah,
they'll all agree the earth is flat,
but they will disagree vehemently or vehemently as
to what evidence there is for that. And there's a
very sort of similar thing here. The audit failed
to point to Trump actually winning. They're
blaming each other. They've got conflicting
reports. And sometimes you have to eat your own
to maintain the lie. That's sort of what they were
signing up for here. And consider the backfire
and the fact that the audit was not just a waste
of time, it was a waste of money. And it actually
ended up showing, if anything, that Donald Trump
was an even bigger loser in Erith, Arizona,
than we originally thought. Will the results be
any different from other audits? Well, in Texas,
they're auditing counties in a state that
Trump already won. So my prediction is no.
If you think anything will come of any of these
audits, if you even understand what it means that
they are doing auditing, I would love to hear from
you. You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman